立っ
あっ
一年ぶりに
二水をしようと思う
本当に1年目ですよ
そろそろマジでちょっと
ず失礼しないと
もうみんなボカーンと思っ
なんかここみのばっかり食べてたら添加物の取りすぎでガンになると思う
失礼します近くの薬局にありました100時間かけた早 c
ポイッ
どーすかを
100時間かけて多分煮込んであるっていうね
なんと思う
なんと燃えたいますね様子やばい作れるかなぁ
よし行きですよじゃあとりあえずなぜこれを
俺が普通に料理すると思ったか
王族の料理見せてやるぜ水2
うさー
#表す後玉でご飯を炊くと思ったか全自治ねそこだぜんっ
阿部なってだけ人数
きたきたきた
うんっこれで見るのを待つだけです
ん
ええええええ
8位
本体を不停出頭してないけど周りの水が沸騰している
怖いわ早く著者らおい
陽気堂
はぁんっ
ご飯を炊くて作業から
金林ないと創るって作業まで全部自分でやると本当に大変だと思った
よし
でしたーー
me
a から実際は大変ですよ
久しぶりの手作りごはん食べてみます
うーん最高に美味しい何だろう
自分で全部作ったというのはあるんですけど
やっぱやっぱり100時間煮込んだということによってすごい
なんか深みのあるはずというか
1週間おいたカレーみたいな
まあ
まあできるだけコンビニ食べるようにするんですけどまあたまにねこうやって
水をして
やっぱり健康的というかこうとか男としてのスキルを上げたいと思うんで
結構難しいんだよねー
みんなそう簡単に出来ると思うよ
ぜひチャレンジしてみてください
じゃあ
ni